Congresswoman Debbie McCaskill Powell
represents Florida's twenty sixth district.
She joins me today. Congresswoman, thanks for
being on. I really appreciate your time. Thank you
for having me, David. The Florida vote is very,
very interesting. Florida as a state may well
determine who wins the presidential election, Joe
Biden or Donald Trump. And then within Florida,
your district may actually signal the way that the
state goes. It's a very interesting district. As
you've mentioned in other conversations, we've
had nearly 70 percent Latino voters. But talk
a little bit about the dynamics there in Florida.
What are the most important issues to Floridians?
Well, first, let me say that you're absolutely
correct. I think that the state of Florida
is going to be one of the most
important states in this election.
The road to the White House begins in Florida.
And, yes, it starts in Florida's 26 districts.
The top issue here has been and continues
to be health care, health care, access.
I represent an area where 70 percent of the people
that live in my district are Latinos, Hispanic,
from the Hispanic community, very diverse
Ecuadorians, Colombians, Argentinians, Mexicans,
many of them are Cuban-Americans.
And for them, during this pandemic,
the spin of it has hit us very hard here in
Miami-Dade County. We became the epicenter of the
of Kofod during the summer. And it's because of
failed leadership locally and at the state level.
And many people lost their jobs. They didn't
have access to quality health care. And the
stakes of this election have become even
higher now that the Senate is trying to
push for that nomination to the Supreme Court. The
Supreme Court, as you know, is going to be hearing
the lawsuit to repeal the Affordable
Care Act. And in my district, David,
we have the second largest number of people
that get their health care through the ACA.
Three hundred thousand individuals in
my district have preexisting conditions.
So if the ACA is repealed, you would see millions
of Americans losing their health coverage and so
many here in my district that would lose that. And
I can tell you that the energy in South Florida,
it has gone up significantly in the
past few months. People are out there.
They're engaged. There are so many grassroots
movements going on in South Florida. They are
coming up for me. They're coming out for Biden.
They understand what's at stake at this election.
And because of their care, because they know
who's going to protect their care. I think
that the energy has really gone way above what
anybody expected within the American electorate.
There are different groups that tend to vote one
way or the other. And as a general rule, three of
the most left leaning groups are Jewish Americans,
African-Americans and Latino or Hispanic Americans
generally within that last group. Cuban Americans
tend to be the most conservative. And there seems
to be this kind of reflexive anti Castro
thing that goes on and that we've seen.
Can you address a little bit? You know, your
district is the perfect place epicenter to see all
of these different groups, as you mentioned, and
their priorities and vote voting interests. Does
this the perspective of the Cuban-American
electorate seem different this time around?
Yeah, and, you know, there is a group of
Cuban-Americans that are very much in favor
of Donald Trump. And that's because there has
been a lot of misinformation spread about the
Democrats there in instigating fear, saying that,
you know, accusing Democrats of being socialist,
which is completely false. And for Cuban-Americans
and for a lot of people that have fled violent
regimes in Latin America. This is scary. And
they've been using that message to divide,
to control that vote. But I can tell
you that there is also a significant
group of Cuban Americans who are 100 percent
behind Joe Biden. They know that Donald Trump
has been an ally of Vladimir Putin. And let's back
up for a second. Vladimir Putin is propping up
the narco regime in Venezuela. The mother regime,
they are propping up Cuba. They are one of their
top allies in Cuba. And Trump is standing right
next to them. So Cuban-Americans here in marry,
many Latin Americans understand that the person
that they need to fear is Donald Trump, because
we're seeing so many signs of someone that's
trying to grab onto power, who is doing whatever
he can going towards the road of an authoritarian
regime. So Cuban-Americans here are now standing
up and saying, no, we do not support Donald
Trump. We are with Biden. There's a group called
Gusanos Combined. But there's also Equatoria
notes, nosecone Biden. So how does Joe Biden and.
That's been a grass roots movement that has
started really by all the Latin Americans
that are living down here that have said
enough, we're not going to follow these
guys anymore. So I'm very optimistic and excited
to see what's happening here in South Florida.
So should we be concerned about the safety
of vote by mail? What do you see as, again,
taking into consideration all of the different
reasons one might vote one way or the other?
What is your message to people about how
it is that they should vote if they really
want to feel good about knowing, feeling
that their vote is likely to be counted?
What I tell everyone here is your vote is still
going to be safe and secure. Do not let anyone
distract you or make you think otherwise.
Our six systems are secure. We have been
conducting oversight along with the FBI. We have
been in communication with our supervisor of
elections here locally. So if you need to vote by
mail because of health conditions, because you're
not here physically, mail that envelope today.
Sign it, seal it, mail it. That's what we're
saying. Just send your ballot early if you can
vote early. We start early voting October 19th,
and you can do that securely as well. Wear a
mask. Use your hand sanitizer. But vote whatever
the plan is for you to vote. Vote. Vote in the way
that's safest for you, for your family vote. Every
vote counts. David, in twenty eighteen, I had
a colleague or one of the candidates in Texas
who lost her election by nine hundred votes.
Gina Ortiz from Texas, who I think welcome
into Congress in twenty twenty nine hundred votes.
Every single vote counts. Again, if you have your
ballot, mail it and sign it, mail it and send it.
It's safe. It's secure. If you can vote in person,
vote early. Don't wait until November 3rd.
We have two weeks of early voting here
in Miami Dade and in Monroe County. We can
change the direction of this country. And I,
I have a lot of optimism because so many
young people are excited. They're engaged.
They're telling their parents their way. Those
deals pretty most pretty much everyone to come
out to vote. And we're going to see that.
We're going to see a huge turnout in 2020.
So this is speculative. It's just your opinion.
But when do you believe we will know the election
results if we vote decisively in Florida?
If we have a decisive win in Florida, that's
going to be a huge indicator that Joe Biden will
be our next president. If Joe Biden wins Florida,
of course, that's what I'm referring to.
If we don't know, it could take weeks.
And so my recommendation is let all of us expect
that. Don't fret. Don't don't get anxious about
it. Let's count every single vote. That's our
democracy. We can be patient. If we've waited
this long, we can wait a couple more weeks. But
my hope is that Florida is so decisive for Joe
Biden that that will be a pretty clear indicator
of who's going to take the White House in January.
Yeah, it's it's it's going to be a very, very
interesting election. Extremely high stakes.
Congresswoman Debbie McCaskill, Powell
representing Florida's Twenty Sixth
District. Thank you so much for your time.
I really appreciate your joining me today.